bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti solo che
io sono qua vige è veramente uscito
gioco ufficiale dell'attacco dei giganti
su playstation 4 quindi come hanno
scoperto che era uscito molto scaricato
immediatamente che bello questa era
insulso cassuto con la [ __ ] la cosa [ __ ]
e che aveva fatto già tutorial e un
macello non avete la febbre non fra ex
finisce un modo per andare a combattere
i giganti io sono eren sono un figo ci
sono già dei titani oddio veramente se
non sono pronto a questa cosa mi aspetta
aspetta destra ha picchiato che ti
faccio alcuno veramente non ho ucciso
scherzavo già battuto un gigante gio
grazie non ci posso credere cos'è che
cos'è a2 sfrutta questo è un attimo il
monte grosso che in atti che zio mykonos
i comandi sono scarso capottata michelin
è il tip tap madonna cosa mi stava
facendo la cosa faceva mobilizzato vai
le gambe vincano reso troppo il braccio
non direttamente alla lunga la nuca
io ragazzi direi che vado a casa dopo
questo come l'anno scorso
cazzo come fanno morire ho fatto adesso
vinto mi sono dimenticato di dire una
cosa per chi non conoscesse l'attacco
dei giganti per uccidere un gigante la
cosa che si deve fare e colpirlo dietro
il collo qua perché è quello il punto
debole dei giganti non ho mai capito
perché sinceramente però per fare queste
cose io ci ho bisogno di gas
ecco gli finisce e per ricaricarlo devo
fare così no
perfetto un casino madonna quanto è
difficile che cazzo passate sulle card è
scemo
[Musica]
parla
ma che cosa ragazzo è successo qua è
scemo cosa stampa perché si è buttato su
una casa a pesce morto già fatta così
impari a distruggere carta e a casa lo
stronzo
datemi la mattina vado a quanto
incassato fase incazzato
tra un morto giobatta miglia sono
fortissime c'è poi allora io ieri ho
passato due ore a cercare di capire come
si combatte perché è veramente difficili
poi non avete idea se solo riuscisse a
ma non al momento pica male
beh vabbè addirittura quattro film
cazzago sono scemi ma che cassinone
pianisti giganti l'abbiamo fatta per
calmo calmo
stai calmo stai calmo
mi chiama tutto bellissimo soprattutto
l'altro live come servito lo stato va
fatta anche lui ragazzi mica sono un
fenomeno finals objection target mica un
obeso gigante ovvero non cos'è sta roba
qui di al boss finale ci sono i posti in
halimi che cazzo di gioco è porca eva
quanto è grosso
devo cambiare gas devo cambiare gli
altri non c erano ceca miglia perfetto
che sarà un 30 metri sto tizio prova
prima ascoltare una gamma ragazzi ci
provo ce l'ha fatta
minchia come ha funzionato bene e morto
ma quasi morto devo fare con quel fino
al collo mai a quando tiri qualcosa ma è
morta non è morto nella cella c'è un ace
quanto è difficile ma quanto ci metta a
morire è che cazzo mi piace l'ho fatta
[Musica]
ma
non mi ha prezzo per con per quanto poco
non mi ha preso più già chi verrà quei
ragazzi ce l'ho fatta non è solo un
commosso sono commosso sss ha dato fatto
dei punteggi della madonna con ragazzi
questa era la modalità spedizione che
quindi puoi fare anche quello tarabara
barba chapter one ritorno di sfera non
solo disperazione disperazione cinque
anni dopo sono passati da quando è
successo a quella roba lì
ultime parole esatto proprio miglia e
anche skrillex entra così paola questo è
il gigante kitano ragazzi questo fa i
culi che ha sfondato tutto sto cristiano
caccia era noi dobbiamo uccidere i
giganti che adesso entrano dal bureau
sono io sono io sono forte
so come si combatte numero di reflusso
pivello guarda come gli faccio un culo
vita ormai prendendo che un fenomeno io
sono diventato un fenomeno solo giuro
ormai i combatte giganti come mangio
sushi dimmi che posso provare a farlo
fuori dal viaggio di roberto baggio
rigore attenzione già che se le fa
fortissimo dovrei servilismi già sarebbe
morto un umano normale così liquidità
corre adesso comincia tutto tip tap 3
tipo davanti a benassi sbloccando
veramente cosa l'ho fatta non scrivo ho
schivato vai questo è un titano medio
ma chi è ragazzi efficiente su vision
sud e che cazzo di resurrection posso
farlo fuori sto cazzo di gigante il
titano
le faccio la pedicure quanto grosso
questo come sta pesando l'altro non mi
pagano di striscio mi passano davanti
non mi pagano
non mi pagano anche come non detto
palamara a strapazza di ora arrivato un
altro che balla tip tap ci siamo quanto
a testa piccola sorgente non uccidono
numerati che non ci sono
ciao frate che cazzo ridi e basta il
braccio e false il collo ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi incredibile c'era già con
dio hanno invaso la città regala sono
curioso di vedere come hanno sviluppato
il combattimento in città non perché
questa cosa fighissima bene resta nel
mese nelle gambe ma dove sono i giganti
eccolo eccolo queste piccolo saldi o
migliaia e premete sul vicolo so io tu
che cazzo sta faci ma sono scemi ma chi
cazzo famiglia che se lo pressa l'avessi
preso quella patriarca
ok che ce l'abbiamo fatta regalare uno è
andato lui mi carica forte pensa di
potercela fare ma io dico da dietro e
san lucido ma che cosa è giusto fare
questa roba che era anche veramente di
cui 29 prova l'unità di sentimento è che
trova agganciato davideco al quadrato
disfare le cose
difficile davvero vengono ri angolo
tagli meno impegni che non è facile
ora è difficile sul serio per come mi
avvicino xxv andria si sta mangiando suo
compagno di triangolo syrian giocare ma
per magliette a melo salvare lo sapevo
io orzo no sì l'ha rivelato la liberato
dove mi accompagno
eccole fondo liberato no no no che mi
prendono che il veloce togliti togliti
ma che [ __ ] prodotta ma adesso
campeggia il naso l'ho staccato le dita
trent marghera discolaccio così brutta
[ __ ]
arturo mi ha fatto male mi ha fatto
malissimo però poi mi curo mi definisco
in acqua fiscale sia in deficiente mi
sono salvato al limite di manco a finire
la spingi nell'acqua
nokia voghera che resiste non può non
vedere i giganti che sono i problemi
visto cosa fanno
sono schemi belli servita merita
l'applauso sta roba
cosa fa cosa sta facendo e scemo no ma
veramente ci sono alcuni che sono
[ __ ] porte davvero raro non ha
preso uno l'ho salvato porca eva gli us
ma edizione dove che devo prendere col e
laila non possiamo prendere le bombole
di ricambio
devo andarmi a prendere quindi durante
la battaglia poi abbandonata lì h ma è
un morto e io preso il gas dei morti ma
la francullo inutile ha chiesto l ora di
cena aprendo il gas dei morti grazie dio
fini stato inutile al bene però almeno
sciolga rispetto per la razza umana
sotto i piedi
già che ci sono ammazzo pure questo ma
[ __ ] di statista barbarica servì a
niente ma mai viene non deve sicuramente
la pomparlo allora perché se non lo
dicevo io stavo di fermat nostri gira
piano mi segue questo fece prima di
ruolo la gente ci siamo ci siamo ci
siamo ne mancano due ragazzi mancano 2
questo mi ha guardato malissimo sei
pronta sia non c'è più non se l'è data a
gambe
a qualcuno ci penso io
parchi è amica si aspetta gli altri mari
cazzola acconciatura non mi ha per
niente schiacciato finalmente qualcuno
che fa qualcosa mi che un ora che
aspetto gli spacco le gambe affetto
uccidi un cielo fucino lo faccio io
aspetto fa chiari anzi ho vinto ho vinto
poi quello che non è che guarda gli
monza sta facendo ammazzo io mica prima
che potesse salire quantum di caparco
gigante ragazzi poi col cazzo
ho salvato
l'ho salvato uno sabato davvero per un
secondo media non ci credo ciao zio e tu
che sei salvo grazie a me mi dai la tua
sorella in cambio grassi soprendono
attaccare adesso mi incazzo
un dato una casa sono vivo e ucciso tra
l'altro mi sento non resta che aprire
una gamba quindi a stato ma dai cazzo
madonna e cellophane noi amiche
incredibile fai anche il boss finale
questo non mi sa che è abbastanza grosso
comprare della madonna acciai minerali
minali allora uno non lo permette a
quanto ci mette landa più ok il braccio
andato e adesso l'ammazzo vai veloce non
lo girano lo uccido gip
morto ma non è morta non è morto minchia
quanto è duro a morire questo ma non era
biondo prima è fatto la sinistra è morto
ma chi era mica sono stanco io no c'è
ancora un cazzo guarda che imparano che
faccia urlata bellissimo questo compito
umano perché mi deve lasciare a me i
compiti più ardui maledizione un gigante
colossale globe atto come quando sono
piccolo ma come fanno a combattere
contro un colosso così opera iniziato a
giocare litio che ha dato assottigliato
in faccia se il mondo
lei la regia faccio ce la faccio io mi
sparo del cannone dove devo sparare ti
faccio non si fa niente non si sta
facendo assolutamente niente
si cerca il braccio su una deficiente su
cava sari è stato il pirlo dopotutto
sono parte alla fine è passato forse la
finestra grazie
non ci parlo io però mi piaceva la patta
ma chi era già tutte ssss ho preso s non
ci posso credere ci abbiamo fatto ma c'è
ancora bassa quantità si manda sei
incazzato
oddio tumefatti della gamma forte
malissimo
mi fanno troppo ridere le facce di chi
ha rinunciato a si stanno mangiando
tutti e se silente armi non è che si è
mosso per evitarlo e non ho le mani le
dita
mica pirla o ne sai quel mangiato a
rimanere in arrivare di manuali e come è
morto
bayern e magari non è di una gamba ma
sei forte usa la terza g è certo sta
cadendo via riparando sull'all in quanto
a ralenti tirano fuori tirano fuori
nicchia che scena etica che era questa
porca eva
[Musica]
che non mischiamo da passacarte
[Applauso]
[Musica]
definito il gioco bellissimo non vi
diremo come continua perché sennò poi
vediamo troppo
ragazzi miei io concludo via episodio
siamo arrivati a toriale ho fatto un
livello però è durato una vita quindi va
bene allora credo che sia piaciuto io
credo che sia veramente fatto da dio ma
veramente da dio è fatto benissimo
fatemi sapere ragazzi se volete un altro
episodio scrivete meno passato nei
commenti come un momento mi piace anche
a persone di facebook e cammello tizian
come al solito ti devo andare a prendere
il telecomando perché non ce l'ho
madonna che ho combattuto contro 800
giganti 6 prendere un telecomando o sei
scemo 13 6 decimi diano prossimo video e
ragazzi
[Musica]